good afternoon everyone
okay we have a special guest as you all
know today today we have uh Mayor
Landrieu Mitch Landru infrastructure
implementation coordinator who's here to
talk about one of the president's
favorite things infrastructure week in
fact he loves this uh week or this
decade right he calls it infrastructure
decade so that's what the president has
coined it to be so kitchen the podium is
yours
everybody Karine thank you very much I
appreciate it uh I thought maybe um what
I do is make a couple of comments and
then if anybody has any questions y'all
okay with with that all right
uh all of you may remember but on
November 15th 2021 just a short
18 months ago or President Biden signed
into law the bipartisan infrastructure
Act
a 1.2 trillion dollar once in a
generation investment in our nation's
infrastructure
and competitiveness
we say once in a generation because it
hasn't happened in our lifetimes uh and
quite frankly it may not happen again in
the in the near future
as you know this is a critical part of
the president's investing in America
agenda which is growing our economy from
the bottom up and the middle out we're
making historic Investments and
delivering Real Results for Working
Families across the country this
investment is not only creating good
paying jobs but it's encouraging private
investment and it's creating new belief
and confidence in the idea that when we
come together we can actually do really
big things in America
while infrastructure week was a punch
line under our predecessor it is now a
reality and it is now in fact going to
be our infrastructure decade next week
actually is infrastructure wheat but now
the difference is we're in full progress
we're breaking ground we're turning dirt
and we're getting it done
there is no way for us to get from work
to home to our kids schools to Alaska
synagogue our church to our playgrounds
to keep the economy humming to get goods
from ships to shells without good roads
Bridges airports ports and waterways
there's no way to keep our economy
humming to make sure that everybody in
America has access to knowledge to make
sure that farmers have access to
Precision agriculture of people that
live in rural areas have access to
telemedicine if we don't have access to
high-speed internet which is why this
bill also makes sure that that happens
everywhere in the United States of
America president the vice president
think that everybody in America has a
right to clean air and safe water which
is why there are billions of dollars to
make sure that we get lead out of the
pipes to make sure that we clean up
abandoned mine lands to make sure that
we clean up orphan well Superfund sites
and Brownfield sites to make sure that
the Great Lakes are cleaned up in the
Everglades and the coastal parts of
America and then finally to get ready
for the existential crisis that is up
upon us now the climate crisis we all
need to prepare for a clean energy
economy that is why this 1.2 trillion
dollar bill is so critically important
to the people of America and that is why
it was on the top of the President's
List we're going to do this on time on
task and on budget we're actually
getting it done to date we have
announced over 220 billion dollars in
funding for over 32 000 projects
reaching over 4 500 communities in every
state in the nation all of the
territories and DC and today we are
launching a new map at build.gov to
Showcase that progress not only for the
32 000 specific projects but for the
major projects highlighting all the
signature projects in all of the state's
territories and in DC and that's a lot
of projects and investments in a short
period of time so let me dig into some
of the details and tell you what that
really means
on the President Biden's leadership we
have begun repair on over six thousand
sixty nine thousand miles of roadway
over four thousand six hundred Bridges
we've invested in over three thousand
new clean transit buses and school buses
for our kids we have invested in
hundreds of Port projects including 13
major port and Waterway projects we've
begun construction on hundreds of
airports including 70 that are already
getting terminal upgrades across the
country and more now these projects as
you must imagine and have heard the
announcements grow uh by the week just
take a look at the work that's happening
across the country as we speak in fact
today we're breaking ground in New Haven
Connecticut on the walk Bridge which
runs from New Haven to Mount Vernon New
York a crucial connector on the
Northeast Corridor for the Metro North
Amtrak and freight lines also today the
Corps of Engineers is breaking ground on
the Final Phase of a 2.9 billion dollar
flood resilience project in Fargo
Moorhead metropolitan area in North
Dakota to better protect that major
health education culturally commercial
center from flooding next week the first
lady will be doing tribal Broadband
project kickoff in Alaska we'll also be
announcing new funding awards for FEMA
resilience grants which are much needed
and I will break ground next week a one
billion dollar series of locks along the
Mississippi River in Illinois Iowa and
Missouri with the Corps of Engineers a
critical project for our farmers in our
agricultural Community as we move Goods
up and down the mighty Mississippi River
now this is happening all across America
from coast to coast and in the Heartland
and everywhere in between all of you
will recall I hope with great fondness
that the president kicked off the new
year at the Brent Spence bridge on the
Ohio Kentucky border where we're
investing a total of 1.6 billion dollars
for that existing bridge and then we're
going to build a new one right next to
it to relieve the congestion and approve
travel time reliability on one of the
most critical arteries of our nation's
supply chain and we're breaking ground
on that project actually later this year
we're also seeing some early projects
get started and actually get finished
just a few weeks ago I was in San Diego
at the West Mission Bay Bridge to
celebrate the replacement of a 70 year
old bridge spanning the San Diego river
that was the largest project in the
city's history and it's going to
transform the day-to-day commute of the
folks that live in that area now as
predicted by President Biden our
investments in infrastructure are
motivating the private sector to
manufacture and build things in America
we are in the midst of a made in America
manufacturing boom all across this
country and we have the receipts in fact
this administration's Investments have
now driven over 470 billion dollars in
private sector manufacturing and clean
energy Investments which are creating
good paying jobs that don't require a
college degree and you have been read
into all of those things in particular
there have been major new private sector
announcements in electric vehicle
charging EV battery rail fiber optic and
cable manufacturing since this
infrastructure was signed just 18 months
ago now moving forward I progress on
infrastructure goes hand in hand with
our economy's trajectory you see the
foundation of a strong economy is
literally our country's infrastructure
our infrastructure is in fact the
Cornerstone upon which all else rests
and is the president often says and
reminds us when we invest in America
when we invest in ourselves we win so
infrastructure week is a punch line no
more it is here President Biden vice
president Harris have delivered now it's
Employee Appreciation week and so I'll
be remiss if I did not just take a
minute to thank all of the folks that
have made this possible the president
has always said when we come together we
can do big things in America so the
president the vice president
all of the cabinet members all of the
federal employees we have 5 000 new of
them who have been working on this
project the partnership with the Mayors
and the governors the partnership with
the business the labor the private
sector the faith-based community and of
course Congress have made this possible
the president the vice president and the
cabinet have made over 300 trips to talk
about this across the country and as the
president often reminds us this is what
a one-team one fight Mission looks like
and why American can do big things when
we come together so 18 months in we hit
the ground running we're now seeing real
tangible progress and now it's time for
us to finish the job thank you all very
much I'll be happy to answer questions
that you might have
uh Mitch can you give us a sense of how
the debt ceiling debate and potential
negative outcome will impact the
infrastructure spending and the law and
can you also give us a sense of how red
states are taking
against it is saying no thanks let me
let me let me do this backwards they're
taking it fast
the red States uh and nobody has has
returned a dollar everybody has been a
ready and willing partner and of course
as I said
um these projects are in all 50 states
they are touching 4 500 communities
they're in the territories and they're
in DC on the debt limit I'll make just a
couple of comments I know that y'all
have spoken a lot about this but as the
president said America is not a deadbeat
Nation avoiding default is a basic duty
of Congress and in fact this is a
manufacture crisis and as the president
said and as I've said to many of you
today there are presidents investing in
America uh agendas working got to keep
the progress going 12.7 million jobs 800
000 manufacturing jobs which is the
proof of the manufacturing boom that we
have 3.4 percent unemployment a made in
America manufacturing boom and of course
as Moody said and you all have all heard
this and reported this a default is
going to cost us 800 000 jobs pushes
further into recession raise the cost of
everything including borrowing and that
really kind of threatens to do all all
of this major progress going forward and
my sense is that we have never been here
before uh at least at this particular
Point nobody wants to see it happen the
consequence is unpredictable but it
can't have anything but negative
consequences on the work that we're
trying to do
thank you for being here if I can ask
you about the debt ceiling conversations
not that you're privy to every one of
these but obviously you're privy to the
process of trying to build around the
country right now how critical is the
idea of Permitting reform and is that
something the administration would be
open to because you think it would make
the job easier uh and something you
should embrace going forward well that
that they're not necessarily connected
as you know
um when when you have the incredible
opportunity that we have in front of us
12.7 million jobs a 3.4 percent
unemployment rate any president in
history would trade uh President Biden's
numbers right now because nobody's come
close to them that's in two years what
most presidents have not been able to do
in four years so when you're trying to
build new things and you're trying to
build things fast
um you've got two major issues that
you're working through one of them is
permitting and one of them is Workforce
and of course from the beginning we have
been working on getting things built
faster and permitting things faster as
you know Senator manchin had a bill that
bill failed that bill's now been
reintroduced the president continues to
support that bill on the executive
branch side we're doing everything we
can to speed up how we actually green
light projects we want to dedupe you
know seriously because things used to go
in sequential order we want to make sure
that we have the right data we want to
make sure that we're doing the right
Community
involvement because if you don't that
has a higher risk of litigation and then
finally we want to make it faster to go
on clean energy all of those things are
are in play and we continue to work it
doesn't hurt in your view it does but
they're not necessarily connected they
were bills absolutely 100 it's better
you've got to go faster we've got to do
better and we got to do more
contingency plans being put into place
when it comes to these infrastructure
projects in the events that there is a
default and then secondly I know that
you are talking to local
country you are a former mayor yourself
have you had any conversations with
Mayors expressing concerns about the
lifting of title 32 and the impacts of
having
well the the secretary was here
yesterday on title 42 and I'm gonna let
him address that in Korean as we as we
go forward and no I haven't had any
conversations with them about that
um but as as it relates to contingency
plans let's just be kind of clear about
this a lot of the money that was in the
infrastructure bill was forward loaded
and is not going to necessarily have an
impact on specific projects
um irrespective of what happens in
Congress unless Congress repeals the
bill when there's no uh there's no
legislation to do that however remember
there there these things don't exist in
isolation so we have hired lots of new
employees those employees have to stop
working that's a challenge
um you have seen what are the potential
cuts a 22 percent cut is going to impact
what the federal Workforce can do or
cannot do if you have a default and
slows the economy down it's going to
have a natural impact on everything that
we're doing in the country and the
public and the private sector but but
the specific technical answer is a lot
of the bipartisan infrastructure law
funding was pre-loaded um and is not at
this moment in play on the kind of
discussions that happened on the hill
thank you mayor
secretary Buddha judge has appeared
where you're standing now and discussed
how federal funds will be used to
redesign urban areas that are assessed
to contain infrastructure that was
racist in its original design and its
original
execution are you collaborating with him
on that effort are any of the
infrastructure funds you're talking
about being used for that purpose
well as you know Equity is really
important to the president of the United
States for the very simple reason that
he thinks that unless we go forward
together it's hard to go forward at all
that's the first thing to remember and
this Administration believes that
diversity is a great strength not a
weakness and that if we're going to do
all of this stuff it's not just a matter
of Justice it's a matter of numbers as
well that's first the second part of it
is this there are in fact highways
waterways roadways if you ask anybody in
the African-American Community or in
communities of color where do you live
they will often say I live on the other
side of and it's usually a railroad
track our water or a highway that's
split historic neighborhoods there is in
fact four billion dollars both in the
infrastructure law and the inflation
reduction act to fund a program that's
called reconnecting communities I was
actually in Fort Lauderdale the other
day looking at some of the damage from
the flood that they had in the mail was
showing me a railroad track that has
separated two areas now they have an
option they could run a Highway across
it or they can build a tunnel underneath
it to reconnect the neighborhoods this
registration things that historically
underrepresented neighborhoods that have
been split apart families split apart
businesses set apart they can be
reconnected to actually heal the
community and create greater Economic
Opportunity is actually a very
thoughtful thing to do and so we're
working on that not only with roads and
bridges but with clean air and clean
water which is what lead pipes about
clean air and clean in in clean buses so
the kids shouldn't be getting off the
school buses drinking that exhaust like
Linus you know having that dust thing
following behind him all of those things
are a part of the work that we're trying
to do in the infrastructure law we're
the urban redesign piece of it is
concerned is that you are Secretary of
Buddha judge who enjoys final
disposition over the allocation of those
funds or this selection of the projects
Etc as the infrastructure coordinator I
don't have final disposition over
anything my job is the herd cats and so
as a consequence what we've done is
we've had 17 different cabinet level
meetings working with each of the
cabinet secretaries so they can
coordinate their activity I've asked
each of the governors in the country
behalf of the president to appoint an
infrastructure coordinator to help
coordinate with us and then I've talked
to 1700 Mayors across the country so all
of our teams can work but all of the
cabinet secretaries are the ones that
are ultimately responsible for making
the final decision on all the grant
programs that come to them and then of
course the other half of this bill is
Formula funding whether it goes by goes
out by operation of law
for being here uh I have a question
about the power of plants and the
administration's clean energy goals uh
yesterday about the epa's new Power
Plant regulations U.S Chamber of
Commerce raised concerns about the
carbon red carbon reduction goals
stating that they go too far too fast
they said that these rules could
threaten power supply and raise Energy
prices harming the entire economy how do
you make sure
um you know how will the business the
Biden Administration convince the
business community that your proposal is
viable and not currently coming well
it's an excellent question and I'm and
I'm gonna I'm gonna send you to
administrator Reagan to answer the
details of that question but as a
general rule for all of this remember
we're doing three things we're building
the team we're getting the money out of
the door and then we're trying to tell
the story everything requires a balance
it's all about timing it's all about
Focus every with everything that we do
somebody will say you're going too fast
somebody will say um you're going too
slow our job is to try to get it just
right and to make sure that this
economic boom that we're having is
steady uh and stable and that we
continue to grow as I will end where
where I finished the president said this
is the backbone this is the Cornerstone
of the economy he has created 12.7
million jobs we have 800 000
manufacturing jobs 3.4 percent we have
momentum now and we ought not do
anything or take any action that slows
us down thank you all so much
thank you thank you all right couple of
things and then the pool's gonna have to
gather at some point and then we'll just
continue
so this Sunday marks one year since a
gunman killed 10 innocent Americans at a
supermarket in Buffalo New York the
president and first lady are praying for
those killed and for those who continue
to Bear the attacks scars both physical
and mental we're thinking too of an
entire community that like our country
was shaken by this attack but then found
Unity purpose and resolve and emergent
even stronger
this attack was a direct blow at the
soul of the nation more broadly the
president continues to take action to
address these overlapping scourges from
issuing a first ever National strategy
for domestic terrorism to signing
Landmark hate crimes legislation to
convening a historic United We Stand
Summit at the White House we have
substantially increased Federal
resources to prevent and respond to
targeted violence and terrorism the
president signed the first major gun
safety legislation in 30 years and has
taken more executive action to reduce
gun violence than any other president
and yet shooting after shooting tells us
there is so much more work ahead to
protect Public Safety National Security
and the fundamentals of our democracy
last year right here at this podium
when this had occurred I shared the
stories of the victims in this attack
their stories are still with us
they were retired law enforcement
Community figures Church volunteers and
substitute teachers
they were mothers and fathers one of
whom was out buying a birthday cake for
his son
they were innocent people who had their
lives senselessly stolen from them as a
consequence of a toxic combination of
hate and easy access to weapons of war
we also honor The Bravery of those in
law enforcement who responded quickly
and with professionalism in Buffalo and
who risked their lives every single day
to protect and serve their communities
Across America and speaking of that
speaking of Bray Law Enforcement
Officers today the White House will
welcome over 500 police officers and
their families for a special open house
tour in celebration of Police Week
officers were invited through a diverse
set of organizations representing and
supporting police officers and will
include members of local and state
police forces from across the country as
well as members of the U.S Capitol
Police in the United States Secret
Service today the president is also
proud to nominate Dr Phil Johnson
Jefferson pardon me Dr Phil Jefferson
to serve as Vice chair of the Federal
Reserve Board of Governors last year the
Senate confirmed Dr Jefferson to the
Board of Governors in a strong
bipartisan vote of 97 91 to 7.
and we look forward to his Swift
confirmation as Vice chair of the board
in addition the president is nominating
doctors Lisa Cook who the Senate just
confirmed last year to an additional
full term as a member of Board of
Governors Dr Jefferson and Dr Cook will
continue to bring valuable Insight
expertise and continue continue to
continue continue to make sure that the
FED at a critical time for economy for
our economy and families across the
country
the president is also proud to nominate
Dr Adriana coogler to serve as a member
of the Board of Governors Dr coogler is
a highly qualified and respected
Economist with deep expertise in labor
markets worker mobility and youth
unemployment she started her career the
Federal Reserve Bank of San Francisco
served as Chief Economist of the labor
department and was confirmed last year
with bipartisan support to serve as U.S
executive director to the World Bank
these nominees understand that this job
is not a partisan one but one that plays
a critical role in pursuing maximum
employment maintaining price stability
and supervising many of our nation's
financial institutions we are confident
these nominees will help build upon the
historically strong economic recovery we
have had under the administration we are
grateful to Senate banking committee
chair Sherrod Brown for his leadership
support in moving these nominations
forward quickly tomorrow morning and
this is the week ahead for all of you
tomorrow morning the president will
travel to Capital One arena in
Washington DC to deliver the 2023 Howard
University Commencement Address
the the president will then travel to
Rehoboth Beach Delaware where he and the
first lady will remain over the weekend
on Monday the president of first lady
will return to the to Washington D.C as
we Mark police week on Monday the
president will release a video to
celebrate and honor Law Enforcement
Officers including those who have given
their lives in a light of Duty as part
of the national Peace Officers Memorial
Day on Tuesday
the president the first lady and the
second gentleman will deliver remarks at
the celebration of Jewish American
Heritage Month the vice president will
also attend
on Wednesday morning President Biden
will honor 2021 2022 medal of valor
recipients from across the country in
the East room for that ceremony the
public safety officer medal of valor
recognizes extraordinary acts of heroism
and bravery on the part of our nation's
Public Safety officers represents the
highest national award for Public Safety
officers the medal is awarded annually
by the president to Firefighters Law
Enforcement Officers or emergency
service service officers who have
exhibited exceptional courage regardless
of personal safety in the attempt to
save or protect human life later
the president will travel on Wednesday
next week the president will travel to
Hiroshima Japan to attend the G7 leader
Summit May 18th to the 21st the
president and G7 leaders will discuss a
range of the most pressing Global issues
including the G7
oh unwavering support for Ukraine
addressing the Dual food climate crisis
securing inclusive and resilient
economic growth and continuing to lead a
clean energy transition at home and for
our partners around the world and before
we take questions I just want to take a
minute to wish all the mothers in this
room and across the administration of
course across the country a Happy
Mother's day ahead of Sunday as the
president said in his presidential
Proclamation recognizing this holiday
across the country mothers are caring
for children providing families driving
Innovative Innovative Innovation across
every field serving at the highest
levels of government including in our
military and across the administration
running companies being journalists as
well let's not forget and they're
helping Drive our economy forward
so this weekend and every day we
recognize the the great strength and
contributions of moms across the country
including the moms working night shifts
and second jobs to support their
families it's why President Biden vice
president Harris and this Administration
are working to ensure all moms have a
have the support they need and the
opportunities they deserve by working to
fully implement the president's maternal
Health blueprint blueprint a whole of
government approach to address the
maternal Health crisis investing in
child care providers through the
American Rescue plan expanding the child
tax credit signing historic
infrastructure manufacturing and clean
energy legislation into law as part of
the president's investing in America
agenda to create good paying jobs for
women in sectors where they have been
previously underrepresented ensuring
women have access to in coverage of
health care services including
behavioral care and ensuring that new
and expecting mothers can thrive in
workplace through new legislation to
bolster protections for pregnant workers
and nursing parents as much as I love
serving as press secretary for the
president of the United States getting
the word or being the name mama will
always be my favorite title so it is a
special day for many of us I'm sure
people here in this room understand and
so with that happy Mother's Day and Zeke
I know this time next year we'll be
saying soon to be happy Father's Day for
you so very excited so
um the president was supposed to be
meeting um this afternoon with
Congressional leaders why was that
meeting rescheduled and she gives an
update on when it will be rescheduled
too yeah just to give you a little bit
of
an update on that so as Speaker McCarthy
said this was a decision uh pretty much
decided by all principals and the
president and the four Congressional
leaders will meet early next week when
we have a date certainly we'll share
that with all of you staff will continue
to meet they're going to meet today and
over the weekend so that will continue
the meetings have been productive over
the past few days and leaders wanted to
continue before they regrouped again you
know as we said we're not going to
certainly negotiate in public we're
going to let these conversations
continue today these are private
conversations and as we said over the
weekend and once we have a date locked
in for early next week we certainly will
share that with all of you clarify a
little bit of what what they are
discussing what they are uh in these
meetings the president's position in
bent but there should be no negotiation
around the debt limit at all power for
this race and so if the president says
there should be no negotiation and they
are talking does that mean he's back off
his opposition to negotiate there is no
not at all he's been very clear we are
not going to negotiate over the debt
limit that is something that Congress
should act on that is their
constitutional Duty what they have been
talking about again I'm not going to get
into the specifics but we have talked
about how Congress should get back to
regular order having those
Appropriations conversation having the
conversation a budget and that is uh
what the president said he is willing to
do willing to have that conversation but
again we cannot have a default and I'm
going to be very clear and you've heard
this from other other leaders as well uh
is uh is that all of the three I have
the three of the four have said that we
have to avoid default they've been very
clear we have to take default off the
table I will let you guess who was the
fourth uh that did not say that and it's
on a different topic
hhsogo confirmed that a a migrating that
an essential boy died in HHS custody a
couple of days ago it's been in custody
for a number of weeks we've been told
has the president been briefed on that
and incident and is there concerns that
the system isn't prepared to handle all
the people who are being interdicted
right now at the border and maintaining
custody as a result of the little late
night as you ordered any sort of
Investigation
so uh thank you for the question it is
uh it is sad news it's deeply saddening
to hear and we are certainly aware of
the tragic loss and our hearts go out to
the family uh and it is uh uh as I just
mentioned being a mother and celebrating
uh Mother's Day on on Sunday uh it is a
very devastating news there is a medical
investigation that was opened on May
10th and so I don't want to get ahead of
that we got to let the investigation go
through and so any specific questions
certainly I would have to refer you to
HHS I haven't actually spoken to the
president about this so I don't have any
information if he's been briefed on this
but I can say that there is a medical
investigation that's that was uh that
was open on May 10th and we're just
going to let that go I think I'm getting
the sign for the pool so if the pool
wants to uh which way should they should
they should exit this way
so I don't have anything to preview at
this time obviously we are saddened very
saddened by by this uh by this loss and
by the news and just don't have anything
to share about an Outreach from the
president on this
just to talk a bit more on the timeline
of Cadet ceiling it's May 12th today
treasury secretary Jenny Allen has said
if it falls can happen soon as June 1st
other forecasters including CBO today
are backing up early June what is the
drop dead date that the White House in
Congress need to reach a deal so that a
Bill gets to the president's desk in
time to avoid the default so look
this should have happened a while ago uh
this is a manufactured crisis as the
president has said as you just heard
from the mayor who was just here at this
Podium this is should have been taken
care of by Congress as their
constitutional Duty a while back
this is not a normal place for us to be
to have to have House Republicans hold
our economy hostage that is not a norm
that is not the norm the regular orders
I just stated when Zeke was asking me
the question is that we're supposed to
have a conversation about the budget
we're supposed to have a conversation
about Appropriations we're not supposed
to be here at this moment where we're
still waiting for Congress to do
something that is been done 60 78 times
since 1960. but we are here in this
moment so what is the level of urgency
there is there is a lot of urgency
obviously there is a lot of urgency
we're talking about potentially millions
of jobs uh being threatened because of
what House Republicans are doing we're
talking about potential uh Devastation
to our retirements account for American
families so this is a incredibly
important point that we're in that's why
the president has used his bully pulpit
for the past several months since
February saying Congress needs to Act
Congress needs to move forward Congress
needs to do their constitutional Duty so
we're going to continue to do that I
just said three of the four that met
with the president on uh on Tuesday said
that the fault should be off the table
so we're all in all on the same place
it's the speaker that needs to really
answer this question and just a quick
follow-up how worried are you that as we
get closer to that date there will be
threats to the economy we saw back in
2011 just getting close to the X State
resulted in a lot of yeah we are worried
we are very worried when you think about
default could as I said 8 million jobs
cause of recession
devastate retirement accounts increase
unemployment by five percent increase
costs for families halt Social Security
Medicare veteran care and all other
government payments those are the things
that could happen if this threat that
House Republicans have put forth moves
forward I mean yes we are very concerned
about this
you're outlining the impacts of a
potential to fall but at what point
should Americans at home start repairing
themselves for these impacts look we
we're hoping that it doesn't get to that
we really are that's why we've been very
vocal the president has been very clear
that's why he had this meeting on
Tuesday to be to be straightforward and
Frank you know this President doesn't is
not afraid to be really honest and uh
and that's why he went to New York to
speak directly to the American people to
let them know what's at stake so what we
hope that this is not going to happen we
hope that the speaker agrees with the
other three leaders in Congress and take
default off the table
decided that he's likely going on this
foreign trip but it's a possibility he
would stay behind what would trigger
that decision what I can say right now
Arlette is that he's expecting to go I
can say that for sure in this moment
that he's expecting to go
42 really quickly you know presidents
answer questions about title 42 but we
haven't seen him do hold a formal event
to talk about this he had that meeting
yesterday with Lincoln and Austin
mayorgas which was behind closed doors
why not have the president out there
speaking about title 42 and the
expectations that people should have
around so the president took more than
40 questions just this week alone
I won't no no no but he he took your
questions uh
twice this week and answered many of
many of those questions on title 42. he
answered the questions that you all
asked and I think that's an opportunity
for the for the American people to hear
directly from him a week ago today he
sat down and had a one-on-one
uh one-on-one interview with one of one
of your one of uh one of your colleagues
here not here but uh clearly in one of
the networks here and talked it out was
asked about title 42. so the American
people have heard from the president uh
when we uh when we again when we were in
New York and again right when uh after
the meeting you heard directly from the
president after the meeting that he had
with the with the big four if you will
and he gave remarks and then two
questions so the American people have
heard directly from him especially when
he laid out how that conversation went
with the big four thanks great uh you
described the uh discussions this week
between White House officials and
Congressional staff as productive what
from those talks uh do you believe is is
pointing to the signs of progress I'm
not going to get into into details of
private conversations what I can say is
from just just a little bit of what I
can give you is that it's been
productive it's been continuing uh since
the the four the big four met on Tuesday
they're going to meet today they're
going to meet over the weekend and I
think that should kind of tell you that
the conversations are going in the right
direction I just don't have more to
share about the private the private
details of of the meetings how stupid to
spending caps on future discretionary
spending as a way to perhaps appeal to
Republicans who have been demanding Cuts
in a package appreciate the question I'm
just not going to negotiate from here do
you think right now we're closer to some
sort of agreement than we were at the
beginning of the week I'm just not going
to get into negotiations for you good
thank you Karine the president said that
he would stay in town until this gets
finished and you said today that he is
expected to leave for Japan on Wednesday
morning so does that mean you are
confident that this is going to get done
before Wednesday morning we're we're
confident that the conversations at
least uh what as it relates to the
budget and the economy as we said we
have to get back to regular order and
have those conversations that the
president has said he's he's willing to
negotiate and happy to debate about his
budget versus a Republican's budget
remember his budget is going to cut the
deficit by three trillion dollars over
10 years and it's going to invest in
America which is what the president
truly cares about and we've seen him do
the last two years so look we're he's
expected to go we're going to continue
to have conversations he's going to
continue to tell Congress to do their
job it's their constitutional duty to
deal with the debt limit as they have
done 78 times since 1960s none of that
has changed and so again expect it to go
and I'll leave it there it has the
marker for whether he will and town
change because initially he said until
this gets finished now it sounds like
you're saying as long as there's
progress being no I'm not no that's not
what I'm saying I'm saying that I spoke
to the president about this he wanted
all of you to know that he's expecting
to go that's where I will leave it I'm
not going to go into private discussions
I'm not going to go into negotiations
not going to do that from here what I
can say is that the president from him
and wants all of you to understand and
know and wants me to communicate that
he's expecting to go next Wednesday
title 42 you said that the American
people have heard directly from the
president why haven't migrants heard a
message from the president or the vice
president
either of them explaining the new rules
or reiterating you know what the
secretary said yesterday not to come
here if you're not going to qualify for
Asylum where are they in terms of
communicating with the people who are
trying to come in I think hearing from
secretary mayorkas is a powerful
messenger he was at the border he has
was here for more than 50 minutes taking
all of your questions he's been on TV
doing kind of a Ron Robin today and
other days as well this week and he's
been very clear what the message is uh
to uh to him to migrants who are coming
look
our message has been very clear uh for
the past past couple of weeks especially
as we've been putting this plan together
uh really for the past past two years
which is uh we got a robust plan in
place to humanely manage the Border
through enforcement deterrence and
diplomacy we've been very clear we want
a system that's Humane that's orderly
that's what the president said on the
first day that he walked into this
Administration putting forth a piece of
legislation that is comprehensive
remember this is a this is a problem
that is decades long secretary myark has
said the last time that we have changed
the law or we've seen laws change around
this issue was back in the 90s it is
more more than time to address this
issue the president is using the tools
that he has in front of him to deal with
this issue and and so he'll continue to
do that but but we have to have Congress
acting and I think I think the president
speaking very loud and clear this week
or taking I should say taking questions
from all of you and also doing an
interview and answering a question about
title 42 and immigration how we're
moving forward I think is also important
I think screen it moved up moved up in
the world
the weather is much better from up there
CBO released new projections uh for the
current economy and this fiscal year
we're projected a deficit of 1.5
trillion last year was 1.4 trillion the
president talks about cutting the
deficit what happened so the president
uh has a track record of a historic
deficit reduction we have seen that 1.7
trillion dollars in the last two years
that is more than any other president
has done in their in their first two
years so that is historic uh that is uh
uh I should say in recent years and that
is something that the president
continues to be committed to because if
you look at his budgets as I just stated
moments ago three trillion dollars
that's what he said he's going to cut
the budget in the next 10 years so he is
committed to that and if you look at the
inflation reduction act if you look at
other pieces of legislation it actually
helps to cut the deficit so the
president is is committed and if you
just to do a little deep dive on the
budget it cuts 200 billion dollars in
spending by strengthening medicare's
power to negotiate for a lower
prescription drug prices it cuts 30
billion dollars in spending on tax
subsidies on big oil companies it
reduces the deficit by 100 billion
dollars by fully funding the IRS so
there are enough agents to thoroughly
look at the taxes of billionaires and
others reduces the deficit by more than
one trillion dollars by making
billionaires and wealthiest pay their
fair share that's what we've put forward
the Republicans in the house put
something very different the complete
opposite that's going to hurt American
families by cutting veteran a veteran
Care by cutting health care and also
making sure that you know law
enforcement as all as well as cut and so
that's what they put forward and this is
the conversation that is happening right
now with the staff the staff members
consumer sentiment went down to 57.7
it's a number but it fell from from a
significant a significant amount is the
president of concern going forward the
consumers are getting less confident
about the economy as we go into the
industry a couple of things I'm glad you
asked that question so the University of
Michigan's release actually cites the
threat of default as a reason
for the full faith in consumer sentiment
so kind of to ouija's question they're
paying attention or someone who asked me
a question about have we talked enough
to the to the American people they're
actually paying attention they're
listening to what's happening what
they're hearing from Congress
Republicans in in the house saying that
they're going to threaten essentially
not saying but laying a plan says
they're going to potentially hold the
American economy hostage so so the same
way refusing to pay our bills would make
a a bank lose trust in you Congress
failing to pay our country's bills would
make the world lose their faith in the
United States and that's what we're
seeing from this particular University
of Michigan's consumer sentiment that
number they make the president more
likely to come to a deal on the debt
ceiling there's no deal to be had on the
debt ceiling there's no negotiation to
be had on the debt ceiling this is
something that Congress needs to do this
is something that they need to act on
this is something that is their
constitutional Duty the president has
been very clear about that very clear
and he will continue to do so
so G7 question assuming the president
goes uh the Prime Minister kashida said
that one of them
[Laughter]
I'm assuming he's going so okay prime
minister said one reason he wants to
hold the G7 in her in Hiroshima is to
draw attention to the the threat of
nuclear weapons I know there's likely
going to be some sort of joint ceremony
to G7 leaders acknowledging this but I'm
wondering as the leader of the country
that made the decision to use an atom
bomb there is President Biden going to
give any separate remarks or have any
separate acknowledgment of events there
so Scott I appreciate your question
we'll have more to share and more to
preview
uh in the upcoming days so look the
president and G7 leaders are expected to
to discuss a range of the most pressing
Global issues including g7's unwavering
support for Ukraine addressing the Dual
food and climate crisis securing
inclusive and resilient economic growth
and continuing to lead a clean energy
transition at home and for our partners
around the world as soon as we have more
details to share of what his day-to-day
is going to look like on this trip we
will certainly share that and likely
hold background calls as well with some
of our policy experts in the NSC to lay
out the specifics
can you tell us how many migrant
children are presently in U.S custody I
I would refer you to the HHS I don't
have don't have those numbers in front
of the site has not reported any data on
this since January and they're typically
reported once a month so in light
especially if this migrant death of a
child
um a couple of days ago just want to
know why that data is not there and if
it's being kept somewhere else if it'll
be released to us well first as I will
reiterate as I mentioned to Zeke who
asked this question our hearts go out to
the family members it is a devastating
news and Incredibly sad saddened to hear
that news there's a medical
investigation that started on May 10th
that's going to we're going to allow
that process to continue as far as the
data that is something that comes from
HHS so I would have to refer you to them
will the administration be working to
track that down because especially after
the New York Times report that uh HHS
lost contact with 85 000 children over
the course of the last two years and
lost immediate contact with a third of
Migrant children that data not being
there is alarming I expect the HHS to
provide that data that is something that
they would have for you to share with
you I just don't have a dad that data
right at this time on the ruling in
Florida last night against these
releases and the fighting
administration's statement in that legal
filing that 45
000 individuals are going to be in
custody by the end of this month we're
not able to go forward with this process
of releases what's the backup plan now
so let me just say on the ruling that
you just you just laid out to me
um so look the way we see that it's
sabotage it's pure and and simple that's
how that reads to us the claims that CBP
is allowing or encouraging Mass release
of migrants and is just categorically
false that is not what's occurring that
is not what's happening and it is a it
is a harmful ruling and the Department
of Justice is going to fight it that's
what we're going to see and we're going
to continue to use every tool that we
have to make sure that we are dealing
with this issue in a Humane and orderly
way and uh and so just last night ice
announced that it is adding thousands
more beds but look Republican elected
officials continue to play games here
they continue to have political stunts
and they don't want to solve this
problem they want to use it again as a
as a campaign tool for them and so what
we want to make sure is deal with this
challenging circumstances that's what we
have done since day one of this
Administration just a couple follow-ups
to the questions asked my colleagues in
the second row uh first is uh what's the
White House's message to progressives
who are reading about the substance of
the talks about spending caps and there
might be expressing some nervousness
what's the message just not going to
negotiate from here we're going to have
a conversation as they have been having
the president is happy to have a debate
to compare what he's put forth to show
his values for the American people as it
relates to his budget and investing in
America how he's going to cut the cut
the deficit by three trillion dollars
over 10 years that is something that the
president is willing to have and uh and
you know we're just not going to
negotiate from here the House
Republicans have been very clear how
they see moving forward and the cuts
that they put forth those 22 Cuts in
veterans and health care and Public
Safety that's going to hurt American
families and I'll just leave it there
follow-up to Scott's question when the
president goes to Hiroshima will he
issue an apology I'll be happy the
United States We're Not Gonna I'm not
going to get ahead of what next week is
going to look like on the president's
schedule just not going to get ahead of
that okay thanks Queen just to follow up
um you just described the ruling as last
night as sabotage pure and simple but it
does change how the administration
potentially handles the situation on the
southern border for at least the next 14
days so what changes may or may
policy wise on this other board but I
can say look I I said this already it's
a harmful ruling we're going to let the
Department of Justice deal with this
ruling what we're going to do and I just
mentioned ice has announced adding
thousands more beds uh and so we're
going to use the tools that we have in
front of us to deal with this issue but
look we need Congress beyond that beyond
the ruling beyond what we're seeing from
the sabotage as I said pure and simple
this is sabotage we want Congress to act
we want Congress to take action and we
just have not seen that again the
president's going to use every tool that
he has as he has been for the last two
years to get this done but we need to
see Congress act the ruling came from
the state of Florida the governor the
Iran DeSantis uh commented about it
today he said maybe it will prompt some
introspection and abide Administration I
doubt it very seriously what they're
doing is a total disgrace so thanks to
Florida for stepping up so let me just
let me just lay out a couple of things
that we have done the last few
first of all we're asking Congress to
act we've been very clear about that the
president put it put forth a proposal to
fix this broken system that has been
broken for decades I mentioned how
secretary mayorka said and we haven't
seen new laws since 1990s and so the
president requested additional funding
to prepare for this transition both as
part of his first and second budget
request and again this past December uh
another thing that we have done is the
president has done is diplomacy we work
to restore our alliances with key
Partners Across the Western Hemisphere
you have seen the type of diplomacy that
we've been able to do with our Western
Hemisphere Partners to deal with this
issue the 20 leaders let's not forget
that met in California just the end of
last year world leaders they came and
they signed uh onto the Los Angeles
declaration for migration that was
really important we've worked with
Mexico we've worked with Colombia we've
worked with Canada we work with Spain
and others to step up enforcement expand
legal Pathways and more so we're doing
that we've expanded legal pathways we're
surging also resources to the Border all
of these are all of these things are
incredibly important and let's not
forget we also have the bipartisan
infrastructure law that help Harden our
ports of Entry so this is what we've
been doing for the last two years last
two years and so again what we're seeing
for Republican officials is completely
um
shameful because it's political play
that's what we're seeing I think I'm
about to be pulled okay I'm gonna do one
last time just to follow up on uh your
comments
sabotaged to be precise are you saying
that Florida attorney general was
attempting to sabotage your policy or
the Trump appointed judge in Florida so
here's what here's what I'll say I won't
specific person I can say that migrants
who do not have a lawful basis to remain
will be quickly removed just like 1.4
million migrants who were expelled last
year alone so that's the truth right but
even before title 42 lifted the Attorney
General of Florida filed suit to
sabotage our effort to humanely and
effectively manage the border and so
that's what we've been seeing from
Republican officials over and over again
for the past several months instead of
trying to deal with an issue or talking
to the federal government how to deal
with an issue maybe in their state or in
their City they don't do that they
actually sabotage what we're trying to
do and I just laid out what we have been
doing what this president has been doing
for the last two years expanding legal
Pathways surging resources to the Border
making sure that our diplomacy was back
on track after what we've seen that was
devastated by the last Administration
from the president so we're going to
continue to do that use the tools that
we have in front of us to deal with a
real challenging issue and that's what
you've heard from secretary mayorkas you
heard from Department of State you've
heard from the OD for the past several
weeks of how seriously we're taking this
issue now that title 42 has been lifted
thank you everybody see you next week